[Music]
i've heard you say before kids don't get
a vote is this true at any age
we're looking into moving our family to
a different continent a small village in
africa for a year of volunteer and
mission work and our teenagers are not
on board
how do we approach this well first i
need to answer the question
a little more carefully or a portion of
this
set it up kids don't get a vote
what that means is the parents are in
charge
right it doesn't mean that i don't
admit that my children have desires and
feelings
about things in some cases that are
valid but
and i take those into consideration but
i make a decision that is best for the
overall family and for that child
i meet too many people where their
children are in charge of their house
and the inmates are running the freaking
asylum and so that's what that
the kids don't get a vote comes from it
doesn't mean we don't take their
feelings
or their desires or their best interest
into consideration in
any major decision we got to talk to
them right and they're worth a
conversation
i before we get to the answer to
extrapolate on what you said to continue
that
understand that when you put your kids
in charge when they get to make
decisions
that taxes them and destroys a child
they don't have the wisdom or the
strength to carry your family
right that's harmful to a kid and not
only is it not helpful it's harmful to a
kid
to expect them to be the kid that
decides are we going to church what
building are we going to where are we
eating
where are we going to live what
neighborhood that a kid can't it doesn't
have doesn't it we used to come out of
church and
we would back after we finally got a
little bit of money could go out to eat
we would say where do y'all want to go
out to eat and it would proceed you know
that
four of them my wife and my three kids
would argue for the next few minutes
until i would just decide
because you know you're right it just it
didn't work right dadgum inmates running
the asylum
and so i look at sharon and go okay me
and you're about to decide this because
i'm tired of them in the backseat those
people in the back seat and getting
brains right
so we're going to just decide and that's
the joke but the the you know the truth
is that i think
you and i would take these teenagers
feelings into consideration it doesn't
mean i won't do it right
uh but and they don't get a vote per se
and they're never you can't expect a
teenager to understand what living in
africa for a year is going to be
is going to do to their hearts and minds
you can't understand it because i've
never done it that's right and so
no no teenager is going to be on board
with hey we're going to leave everything
you know
go to another country away from your
friends your family your community your
church all of that we're going to start
over completely for a year
your instagram is going to get totally
screwed up everything's going to be
messed up right
so go into it with a different mindset
but no they don't
if you and your wife think that's the
best interest for your family
for dragging kicking and screaming i
would
i would think there is something wrong
with my teenager if they're not
kicking and screaming okay because they
don't know any different
yeah right they don't know unless they
just you've you've trained them to have
a robust sense of adventure
right now if you're living out some
fantasy and this is against the best
interest of your
kids we're all gonna i'm gonna sell the
house and we're gonna move to tennessee
to pursue my songwriting career
we're all going to live in a one-bedroom
apartment because i'm not going to have
any money and the kids say that's a bad
idea
right they're being more adult than you
are at that point you're right right
right but yeah
so
i i wouldn't expect the teenager to be
fully invested because they wouldn't
understand they don't have the wisdom to
look down the road they don't have the
wisdom to
understand that my innate discomfort is
not going to pay off
in massive ways down the road
yeah i i agree i'm trying to think
um about when our kids were there if we
had wanted to do something like that
what would have happened
they would have objected absolutely no
question about it
but i also would like to think we never
did it
so i really don't have a test case but i
would like to think that
some other times that i had challenged
them on something and said
you know you didn't want to do this but
we did it because i thought it was a
good idea it worked out
then um you know maybe i'd made some
deposits
there you go in earlier before i get to
this decision
so if only deposits you've made if all
you've done is make withdrawals up to
this point and dad's constantly going on
an adventure
and it's constantly putting everybody in
peril and the kids are tired of the
emotional up evil
for a dad chasing this weird adventure
thing he's got uh
then yeah you know i would give them
that you know they're i'd give their
voice much more credence
but if all you've ever done is make sure
that they're okay
and other times you've stretched them
and it turned out good to their benefit
and they smiled but they didn't think
when you went on that vacation it was
going to work out
and now this is another one then you've
earned the right
to force their hand those relational
deposits right and
my hope would be that this isn't one of
those things that someone was driving
home from work and they thought
i hate my job it's time for me to do
something drastic my hope is when you're
going to make a transition like this
it's been incremental and welcome you've
taken your family there before for a
week or two
you have shown them videos and pictures
and you've met families from there and
you have it's a part of the fabric of
your life right
exactly one of the best things we did
with our teams was send them on missions
trips but they were a week long
right you know or whatever and or they
went you know sharon
went on several the trips with them uh
because they get out of the
prosperity bubble right and see uh you
see real world poverty that's right
and see people that are happy in spite
of living in a cardboard box and
so it redefines happiness it's not based
on stuff or electronics or
screen time uh it's reset and bust the
bubble
right you know and so it was very
valuable in that regard
this would be a bigger version of that
right these kids could come home
changed transformed forever right and
that's where i say
again a teenager can only feel in right
now
they're not fully developed that's why
we don't give them car keys that's why
we don't give them
the ability to vote or to fill in the
blank right because we have all decided
they don't have the maturity to handle
some of that because they live in the
right now
in the what is going to keep me
comfortable and keep me engaged in my
community right now
and they wouldn't have the wisdom to see
beyond that but i love what you said man
there's got to be some relational
deposits along the way so if you're
going to make life transitions
i don't feel guilty about forcing it if
i'm not being irresponsible absolutely
not and if i have made deposits that's
right if after that they're throwing a
little hissy fit and they'll just have
to do it
and i would expect them to their kids
yeah i know but i mean i'm just saying
that that's part of the equation but i'm
okay
i'm not going to be going oh i've ruined
my child's life because they actually
are going to say you've ruined my life
that's actually a phrase
i hate you you're killing me you're
ruining everything i loved that boy
right all the stuff my instagram's going
to go dormant that's right i'm going to
lose all my followers
yes all the the super tragic stuff right
yeah that's yeah
it's all over for when that happens yeah
yeah you're gonna your ability to do a
reality show later is going down the
tubes and so
darn it that's awful i hate it that that
happened